okay there's a program called the Reuben
report where people of all political
backgrounds are interviewed mostly
conservatives actually Dave Rubin as a
cultural critic and interviewer is more
like say Larry King from what I've read
then some other interviewers in that
it's not so much about Dave debating
people in playing point counterpoint or
pushing back against the things that the
guests say it's more about hearing ideas
from his guests what do the guests think
what are the guests believe what do the
guests want to see happen in politics
and culture and society and today I have
clips for you from an interview he did
with a woman named Brigitte great
Gabriel who is absolutely one of the
most vile right-wing extremists that the
conservative think tank industrial
complex has ever produced
in a sort of less than Dave Rubin like
fashion he actually interject Edurne
this interview more of his own ideas and
positions into the conversation for
example suggesting that anti George
Soros conspiracy theories can't be
anti-semitic because quote everything he
does is usually against Israel but I'm
sort of getting ahead of myself here
we're not there in this exploration just
yet what I want to focus in on here as
we explore this interview with Brigitte
Gabriel is are the things Brigitte
Gabriel is saying so outrageous that not
calling them out must be denounced when
I last interviewed Dave Rubin I gave him
some examples where I as an interviewer
would come prepared and say hold on a
second that's not right so one example I
gave him is during an interview with
David Horowitz some time ago
Horowitz said Obama is a communist
that's demonstrably untrue it's silly
it's nonsense and I'm not sure what the
format gains by not simply pushing back
against that and saying well what the
hell are you talking about or maybe more
politely can you give some examples of
socialist policy that president obama
has either proposed or enacted as
president so Dave and I spoke about that
reasonable people can disagree about how
to handle that depending on what you're
trying to get out of the interview but
in this interview that I'm going to play
pieces of for you that Dave Rubin did
with Brigitte Gabriel she repeated the
endlessly debunked conspiracy theory
that George Soros worked with the Nazis
and not only did Dave Rubin not rebut it
he actually appears to agree with it not
once but twice ok let's start getting
into this and the point of all this is
to show first of all for the people in
our audience not familiar with this
program just to give you an idea of how
these interviews with right-wing
extremists go on the program but also
just to think about whether the
positioning of Dave Rubin as the
interviewer who just asked questions is
giving us something of value when the
guest says things as crazy as what
Brigitte Gabriel said here in my book I
have a whole section about Soros and I'm
funding the media Soros right now has
spent doesn't that make you an
anti-semite if you talk about Soros
that's their new meme so Dave says their
new meme is that talking about Soros is
anti-semitic of course that's not true
right I mean if the idea is to seek
nuance and explore ideas in detail
instead of this cartoonish sort of black
and white way we would say you know
talking about Soros criticizing Soros is
obviously not inherently anti-semitic
but criticizing Soros as a proxy to
portraying Jews as conspiring to use
their ill-gotten riches for the
coordinated control of the political
system or media or whatever well yeah
that's actually part of an anti-semitic
tradition that goes back hundreds of
years and is part of thousands of years
of oppression of Jews but saying the
meme is if you talk about Soros you're
anti-semitic it's pointless it does
absolutely nothing to really generate
debate or any kind of battle of ideas
let's continue I didn't even know he was
Jewish I'm tell about a year ago right
and everything that he does is usually
against Israel the height of stupidity
so again just blistering with logical
fallacies Soros does things against
Israel so therefore criticizing the
criticizers of George Soros cannot
possibly be anti-semitic I mean yeah you
would think he sounds and talks like an
anti-semite much more than me remember
he is the one who works with the doctors
with the Nazis yeah and actually had a
smile when people asked them how did you
feel about going in and working with the
Nazis against your own people he said
well you know somebody had to do it so I
know I gotta see any problem with it you
know yeah you're not making that up
either no no I mean I watched his
interview because I was very interested
on what makes this man the way he is I
study my enemies okay
so actually Reuben agrees twice here
with the Soros worked with the Nazis
thing he says yeah the first time and
then he says you're not actually you're
actually not making that up the second
time that Brigitte Gabriel keeps talking
about this the allowing of that debunked
conspiracy theory to be recited not only
without pushback but actually agreeing
with it is directly fomenting
anti-semitism and what this relates to
is that listen first of all understand
George Soros was born in 1930 okay he
was nine when the war broke out and 14
when the Nazis surrendered in 1945 you
had to be seventeen to join the SS so
number one there's a picture that floats
around supposedly of George Soros in an
SS Nazi uniform that literally could not
have been him and it wasn't it's a guy
named Oskar graining that's number one
the next layer of the conspiracy is okay
fine
Soros wasn't in the SS but he was a Nazi
collaborator and Glenn Beck and Alex
Jones and Dinesh D'Souza were involved
in spreading that one and all of this
relates to a sixty minutes interview
that they'd like to point to which
includes steve Kroft asking George Soros
about whether he was involved in the
confiscation of property from Jews and
there's a moment where George Soros is
completely taken aback by the question
and I encourage you to watch it and it
sort of seems like he said yeah I was
involved in in taking property from Jews
of course we now know the truth of this
and
later in the interview George Soros
makes it clear that he doesn't regret
anything he did because he didn't do
anything he saw this happening and what
happened was that George Soros had a
caretaker during World War two who was
forced by the Nazis to inventory to make
lists of properties that the Nazis
seized from Jews one time George Soros
went with that guy when that guy was
taking inventory of properties okay
that's what happened and to allow or
even agree with the perpetuation of that
conspiracy theory is absolutely and
totally disgusting and then it becomes
truly dangerous literally pushing
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
then Brigitte Gabriel goes further
pushing the idea that Soros personally
approves the talking points of media
this is the conspiracy theory that
Jewish rich dudes tell the media what to
say
take a look this is exactly how we end
up with reporters who are no longer
reporters they are activists with a
national platform media platform who get
on television every night and basically
spew the same [ __ ] political points
approved by serves and they all say the
same thing whether it's a Huffington
Post the New York Times The Associated
Press Reuters MSNBC CNBC ABC the same
buzzword and it's all coordinated
I actually saw some comments about this
on our YouTube channel there was a day
last week where my commentary about
something related to immigration was
similar to the commentary on The Young
Turks and people were saying Soros is
dictating the talking points David
Pakman and the Young Turks are both
getting their talking points from the
same people obviously this is insane
I've never had any contact with Soros I
don't watch The Young Turks I just don't
have time to watch any other shows it
might just be that a story came up and
multiple media outlets came to the same
conclusion battle of ideas right these
are the ideas that were presented by
Brigitte Gabriel and
they were not even remotely opposed then
lastly and this is just I mean that the
the lowest of the low brigitte gabriel
compares herself to anne frank i don't
even know that this part requires
analysis see I am the Anne Frank who
lived to tell about it can you imagine
if Anne Frank was alive and the Nazis
were spreading worldwide and she just
escaped the concentration camps and she
came to the United States and Nazism
started rising in the United States she
would be saying the same words that she
said when she was alive and with me in
my case I started speaking after the
attacks on 9/11 on the United States I
started speaking about the threat of
radical Islam to world peace in our
national security
this part is merely delusional I mean
there's just no way in which Brigitte
Gabriel is like Anne Frank I actually
recently reread Anne Frank's diary and
I'm seeing a bit of a gap between Anne
Frank and Brigitte Gabriel so let's see
if we can categorize this a little bit
interviewing conservatives like David
Brooks or Thomas solo and hearing out
their ideas that's quite reasonable for
an interview show like this one I have
no problem with that at all bringing on
people like James d'amour
from the Google memo or this guy named
Carl Benjamin he goes by Sargon on the
internet that's starting to get sort of
fringe but it's like okay if you don't
want to push back about about what they
say fine it's kind of dumb but don't
push back against it when you start
bringing people on like stefan molyneux
and brigitte gabriel first of all as if
they even have big ideas to present to
us right they just spout this nonsense
unopposed these are extremists radicals
i have no problem with them being
interviewed I interview extremists but
it needs to be responsible platforming
and likewise I used to have an invite to
do Dave Reubens show I don't know if
that invite is still open at this point
I don't know if it were and I did that
show I would expect to be challenged on
my views
I would not assume that I can show up
and just say whatever I want with no
critical a critical analysis happening
as it's taking place in real time it's
more a question of whether
Reuben feels okay doing an interview
with someone like Brigitte Gabriel in
this way
how does he rationalize handling it in
this way privately I get how you do it
publicly but I don't know how I'd live
with myself privately if I did
interviews in this way it's like if I
had Richard Spencer on and I said oh how
interesting novel and fascinating new
ideas great I couldn't do something like
that I couldn't live with myself I also
don't really understand why Rubens
funders like learn liberty the more
libertarian minded folks I don't even
know how they are okay with Brigitte
Gabriel being allowed to come on insight
unsubstantiated debunked anti-semitic
talking points with no challenge like I
don't even know how that helps their
brand in their partnership but that's
not really my business that's for them
to figure out absolutely and completely
off the rails send me your thoughts were
on instagram at david pakman show quick
break back after this one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
incredible online learning community
offering over 10,000 high-quality online
courses on a huge variety of topics
first 500 who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class that Skillshare offers you'll have
free access to courses on music art
photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you just took a really great
class on graphic design which I know
nothing about but I'm trying to learn
our show is giving you two entire months
of totally free access to every course
Skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video you'll have
two months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share that passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up